all right uh taking a turn to some other
folks that we are rooting for as part of
a new series that we are introducing to
you this morning right now as you're
hearing my voice we're calling It
Mixtape moments boom there's the
graphics package roll it we're gonna be
taking turns over the next few weeks
sharing a song from an emerging artist
and I am up first I want to introduce
you all to an up and coming country
artist her name is Tiara Kennedy and
here's a little bit from her song
founded in you
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it is a very sweet and very very country
and very catchy yeah
is it me or is she like showing up a
little Kelly rolling up in there yeah
she got a little Kelly Rolling in the
face could be could be this is her debut
single uh and she says the lyrics by the
way uh were inspired by her husband
calling him the song uh uh calling him
in the song the best part of me she's
saying found it in you she's talking
about him and she's going to be
performing at the popular country music
festival Stage Coach that's coming up in
April have you been that is awesome I
have not been I'm not you know I don't
know if people trust my musical taste I
think I think she's great right so trust
trust yeah but you recently learned how
to dance so we could see those moves at
the festival
maybe maybe check out more of Tiara
Kennedy and other songs and artists that
we feature here go to our Spotify
playlist just search for CBS morning's
mixtape and scan the QR code on your
screen we are updating it weekly with
songs and artists that you hear on this
broadcast so we can take all the Jabs
you can take all the jams on the go yeah
on the go